just to give you a break in line coming
into us from jet to them sent a tweet in
the last few moments where they say in
response to local measures introduced
throughout Spain to prevent the spread
of covert 19 including the closure of
bars restaurants shops and activities
including any watersports we have taken
the decision to cancel all flights to
mainland Spain the Balearic Islands and
the choleric Canary Islands with
immediate effect
we know these local measures will have a
significant impact on our customers
holidays which is why we have taken this
decision they go on to say we are
contacting our customers who are
currently in these destinations and who
are due to travel to advise them of
their options so we urge customers not
to call us this is a fast-moving and
complex situation and we are reviewing
our program as a matter of urgency
so that we can fly customers back to the
United Kingdom so jet - saying that they
have cancelled all flights to mainland
Spain the Balearic Islands and the
Canary Islands with immediate effect
you